we got happy burger right it was a
buzzer beater order
and they were you could see they were
just about to turn all the girls off and
then we're like yo
oh no you're one of those [__] you
yeah
that's what you're gonna be dealing with
oh yeah you're right [__] once you get
that food truck no I just feel like I'm
sold out sorry
I like working in food I'm just I'm
stressed because
when it's time to [__] cook like it's
very stressful because I used to work at
Subway yeah and so yeah definitely the
same thing it is it's definitely the
same thing it is when you're in it like
when you're [__] cooking and managing
like [__] five orders like it's hard
yeah like the lunch rash and [__] like
that because it's like [__] do they want
the meat that's microwaved or the meat
that's been sitting here pretty that's
fake yeah it's like veggies are fresh
yeah are they those Slanders something
like that are they are they fresh the
veggies are fresh yeah they come in two
days three days every every three days
the me
at yeah if you guys go to Subway I'm not
saying don't eat Subway you know I mean
you know yeah we look at that meat that
they they look like I'm just say don't
eat the tuna yeah
just don't eat it okay
all right welcome with me just doing a
little fast and furious bit right here
no just don't either doodle I swear to
God do you know how the tuna is made no
Subway you probably look it up basically
they take you like uh what are those
like Marine like food bags or whatever
but the MREs
you mean um uh you mean a CSM uh sure
sure I guess yeah a comedy Soldier meal
oh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
what the boys fighting for free speech
have to Chow Down my bad bro I'm from
Orange County yeah yeah you wouldn't
know you wouldn't know what it's like
being in Schaumburg Illinois at midnight
not a single place open to eat see yeah
a U.S judge rules that Subway can be
sued over it's 100 tuned to claim it
comes in these things
bags bags and they [__] have to like
a tub or like a bag of mayo oh they just
[__] dump it in and just mix it nice
it's the most grotesque like roses
visual yeah and it's not good it's not
fresh the tuna's dry as [__] it looks
like something you're Conjuring there's
no detectable tuna DNA yeah just don't
eat the tuna sorry whatsoever just don't
eat the tuna so the tuna is 90 male yeah
for the most part and then we just uh
such as chicken and pork yep and guess
what you know the grilled chicken breast
at Subway yeah they grill the grill
marks I mean they dye the grill marks oh
so it's not even like actually grilled
they just like kind of stamp it I mean
you could tell when you eat that [__]
how rubber it is
I used to get those back in the day and
just yeah no I did a clopin shift at
Subway when I was working there a what a
clothing you never heard of a clopin oh
of course this guy never worked a real
job
I'm gonna work some real jobs
yeah so where you close and open so you
closed the night before and you open the
next morning so it's like you close at
like 9 p.m 10 p.m and then come in 5 a.m
uh and open the store yeah I've done a
few clopenings
and uh I remember it was like 5 a.m 6
a.m this lady walks in
and she goes yours I ordered the chicken
teriyaki and it got me sick and I had to
pump my stomach for like six hours this
is five six a.m she's telling me like oh
my God like [__] like I'm so sorry let
me call the manager let me like figure
something out she's like yeah I got blah
blah blah like I was in there all night
like just getting my stomach pumped and
I was like okay I'm gonna call she's
like no I'm just here for another
sandwich
foreign
and so she got the same exact thing that
got her sick
and then I was just like I was like okay
like uh it's I'm Gonna Bake it for free
I guess she's like no no I'll pay for it
I'll pay for it and then as she's
leaving the door with her sandwich she
goes better not get me sick
that was so [__] you know the phrase
fooled me once before we started saying
we'll see who's the fool gets it again
retail is such a hilarious place like
the weird interactions you have the most
brutal cloaking that I used to do when I
worked at Best Buy
was closing the night before [__]
Black Friday oh you're [__] by coming
back at four in the morning oh my god
dude those would suck do they like barge
in do they do like the oh man they would
we actually the best Best Buy had a
pretty good system for it but people
would camp out it was like the same
people every year too
they would start
there were repeats thanksgiving's always
what the third Thursday yeah
so I want to say these people would
always start on Monday [__] it was
always a good four or five days before
and man it was it it it was like a
full-on tent they're just there
yeah you would see them every day yeah
walk in yeah they'd have someone holding
it was insane
and
what was interesting was I got to work
at Best Buy
right as I feel like technology like had
turned a corner it was like right when
um
you know like TV brands like TCL were
coming out right right uh Best Buy had
figured out oh we can we can sell these
same flat screens for dirt so they're
making like Insignia TVs and like all
their Best Buy brand TVs so it was like
right as that stuff was really becoming
like common so
as those couple years passed
the diminishing return on camping out
the night before it was like the fall
off was crazy
I remember we'd be looking at these ads
thinking to people camping out for this
like there's literally there's nothing
to camp out for and the thing that they
would camp out for mainly every year
were these like 300 e-machine laptops
they would go nuts for them really yeah
or Chromebooks or some [__] it was like
before Chromebook yeah
um they were just really cheap laptops
and people thought they were getting a
steal but it was like these [__]
shitty laptops with like one gig of RAM
they're just like barging in there you
know I I think the only other things
were you know maybe like Limited stock
on new Xboxes and stuff but I can't
really place
when those years were versus like when I
worked there but yeah I think it was
really weird because we were that
generation coming up realizing Oh Black
Friday is stupid and all the people
lining up were clearly people from like
10 years ago yeah yeah like I'm gonna
get the yeah yeah the deal yeah yeah and
then when you know so then when you go
in for the open Best Buy is pretty good
about how they handle that [__] they'd
set up a bunch of makeshift registers
yeah and you were just scanning [__]
from like [__] 5am and you worked it
you're just getting them yeah
yeah that was when you could get
um cables and other like Best Buy brand
stuff for 10 above cost they changed
that what is it now I think you they
only get a 10 discount but before dude
that that was crazy but we needed like
HDMI cables or anything like you know 16
like [__] 63 cents dollar ten [__]
yeah
um just random
yeah you get TVs like 300 bucks that was
that ripped that would have been [__]
nice yeah unless you work back for like
a year
um set up a studio in your crib yeah
I've always thought
you know it would be fun to just go work
seasonal
just apply
yeah just see if I could get back in see
if I still got it
that's what I'm gonna feel like with the
Kebab track yeah man I still got this
yeah no dude no that's gonna be way more
it's gonna be sick I'll drive it by here
and everyone else can eat it yeah drive
by where in space Oh into space yeah
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]